so unfortunately the spider-man far from
home trailer release date was delayed by
Sony you're all right I don't know I
don't know what's happening
it was supposed to come out today in the
CC XP in Sao Paulo Brazil but it didn't
it got pushed back but there is some
good news they did premiere the trailer
at CC XP although they are not releasing
it online at this point many people saw
it and we have reports of what was shown
in this trailer so of course I'm here
with the trailer description for you
just the heads up still doing a giveaway
giving away a life-sized Infinity
Gauntlet the winner will be chosen on
New Year's Eve if you'd like to enter
for your chance to win all you have to
do is subscribe to my channel like this
video and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero so
right away it sounds like this trailer
isn't going to be anything what we quite
expect it to be there is zero
acknowledgement of Avengers infinity war
or Avengers endgame at all it sort of
just picks up right after spider-man
homecoming so according to Tom Holland
himself the movies going to follow
spider-man and Mysterio as they team up
to take on the elementals so we have
spider-man and Mysterio working together
which is kind of a shock because I think
everybody believed that Mysterio is
supposed to be the main villain in
spider-man far from home but one part of
the trailer description is that Mysterio
is actually pretending to be a hero so
the trailer starts off with Peter Parker
at a school event and it shows the
journey of his vacation spider-man is
famous now and Peter Parker is going to
Europe with some friends on tour so he
prefers to leave his classic uniform in
New York upon arriving in Venice he is
approached by Nick Fury and is recruited
for a mission to defeat a villain made
of stone and water again they mentioned
elementals and there's already been
reports of many villains being in this
movie hydro-man molten man electro so
many villains are said to be in this
movie apparently while he's fighting
this villain Mysterio appears and saves
the day by pretending to be a hero so
Mysterio is the master of illusions he's
a trickster so it's most likely that
he's just trying to trick Peter Parker
while talking about the film Jake
Gyllenhaal revealed that Mysterio was
someone originally hired by Nick Fury
for a different mission let things end
up going bad so perhaps he starts off as
good but then once something happens
with Nick Fury things go wrong and ends
up being a villain but according to Jake
Gyllenhaal this movie is going to be
focused around spider-man and Mysterio's
relationship and here's a
direct quote from what he said at cc XP
the central point of the film is the
relationship of Peter with Mysterio is a
completely new dynamic based on what
we've heard Mysterio is probably kind of
good but mostly bad again in the trailer
description it says he pretends to be a
hero so he's clearly trying to use
spider-man for something in fact I would
not be surprised if all of the villains
and spider-man far from home are simply
illusions created by Mysterio the
trailer apparently has some spectacular
action scenes and some romance there's
romance between MJ and Peter Parker and
Aunt May and happy Hogan I don't feel so
good which I'm very curious to see how
that happens in the movie so that's it
for the trailer description for the
official spider-man far from home
trailer that was shown today at CC XP in
Sao Paulo Brazil just to sum it up it
starts off with Peter Parker going on a
trip to Europe he decides to leave his
classic spider-man suit in New York
which is why we'll see him in the
stealth suit in Venice when he gets to
Venice he's approached by Nick Fury and
asked to do a mission for him when
Spiderman is on that mission and is
fighting a villain Mysterio shows up and
saves the day by pretending to be a hero
but is most likely a villain the trailer
shows a lot of action scenes and some
romance the trailer will not acknowledge
Avengers infinity war or Avengers 4 at
all and according to Jake Gyllenhaal the
movie will be focused around the
relationship between spider-man and
Mysterio apparently the trailer was so
good that the audience applauded for
five minutes after they showed the
trailer so let me know what you all
think about this trailer description in
the comments down below as far as the
official trailer date for Spider Man far
from home goes there is no official new
one set yet although it is rumored to be
here before next Thursday which makes
sense so it can show during the Spider
Man into the spider-verse trailers but
we could get it as early as Monday so of
course I'll keep you all up to date
again don't forget to tell me your
thoughts on the description down below
and don't forget to subscribe to my
channel so you can enter the giveaway
and stay up to date on everything
related to Avengers in game and
spider-man far from home as always thank
you all so much for watching woof woof
[Music]